good evening all it's at six o'clock
london time on the third of september
2020
welcome to this week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator
television
this is the inaugural broadcast of
spectator tv
there'll probably be lots of technical
hitches but we hope you'll bear with us
and that this will be the first of many
to come
thank you all for joining us on this
special occasion for us
a special thanks to the netwest group
who are
supporting this inaugural broadcast
tonight the nat west group
is the biggest supporter of businesses
across the uk
and is working especially hard during
the pandemic
to do everything it can to help
businesses and personal customers
get through this period we have
assembled a star
study to cast from the spectator
actually we just locked the doors to
make sure they couldn't get out
until the broadcast went on air we have
the editor of the spectator fraser
nelson
katie balls the deputy political editor
of the spectator and james forsyth
the political editor of the spectator
earth special guest
tonight is professor carl hennigan
director of the
center for evidence-based medicine at
the university of
oxford we had tried to get someone
who was an expert in no evidence-based
medicine
but prince charles wasn't available for
us so
spectator tv launches today on the same
day that harry
and megan announce a hundred million
dollar contract with netflix uh
we're launching ours simply on a wing
and a prayer harry and megan have
promised and i quote
impactful content that unlocks action
there you go i just can't wait for more
we would simply be glad if you watch
this and absorb what we have to say
we don't mind if you want to sing rural
britannia at the end or even during
feel free we really care if you want to
sing the red flag
but just keep it to yourself we want to
cover some of the important topics
uh that have dominated the headlines
this week and i'm afraid
that means we have to begin as every
broadcast has to begin
uh in the past six months almost with
covert
matt hancock announced today that he's
investing 500 million
in trials for a 20-minute covert 19
saliva test it's part of a mass testing
strategy
now a lot seems to be writing on this
scheme the health secretary said
that families may be able to hug each
other at christmas
if a mass testing program is in place by
then
now the announcement came as weekly
cases were revealed
to be at the highest level since the end
of may
this is fuel talk of a second wave with
cases in spain
several other countries including france
now rising so will britain be next
what does the data say let's go straight
to fraser nelson
thank you andrew well our understanding
of cuba has come a very long way since
right at the start so i understand that
ministers had no idea
there was such a thing as an
asymptomatic cobit case
later on we should learn that as many as
four in five cases
can be asymptomatic that puts a very
different perspective when you see the
number of cases rising
and it's far from clear what this
necessarily means
uh we've had local lockdowns uh based on
the fact that cases are rising
but we heard em graham brady tory mp and
chairman of 1922 community this morning
saying that you should be looking at
other things like hospital admissions
because tests going up is not the full
picture
now the first country to see this was
spain
and um i'll show you here on the screen
you can see
spain's second wave it's in blue it's
all quite clear
and it's going up almost as high as it
was in the first peak
but what's significant is the deaths in
spain why they followed cases
quite heavily the first time around the
second time around
they haven't of course there is a lag
between the rise
in cases and any potential rise in
deaths which is not
a lag that we've seen very much of so
far and this has been seen
right around europe we also had um leo
verratka who's got a lot more time in
his hands nowadays
pointing this out he was pointing out
all the in ireland you're getting a lot
more
positive tests but with no illness no
hospital increases no deaths the same
pattern
across europe and now this brings us to
what's happening in britain these are
our cobit cases you mentioned earlier on
andrew that the
the levels now are at the highest since
may well this is what we're looking at
the people
and testing pcr positive to covet
but then have a look at the number of
people in hospital with cobit symptoms
that is a very different picture is
going down
steadily there's no uptick in that at
all so what we're seeing
is here as with spain a strange
decoupling
of covet cases and the serious illness
the hospitalizations that stem
from those cases when we look at the
number of
patients and ventilators the very
serious case again like the hospital
cases that is going down without any
signs
of increasing so this um raises
interesting questions about how we
diagnose the spread of cobit what policy
makers are supposed to do when they're
thinking about whether to lock down a
locality a city
or a country if you look at bolton where
am which thought it was going to be free
from lockdown
earlier this week only to find out it
wasn't you can see the um
number of cases increasing there that's
what changed them ministers minds as
well as pressure from
local authorities but again look at the
hospital beds occupied that data is
lagging
but there's no sign yet of any increase
in illness
so this is what takes us to a very
interesting
step in our stage in our understanding
of the pandemic
what should we be looking for should we
be changing policy as our understanding
of the data changes
and what indeed is that evidence
telling us back to you andrew fraser
thanks for that
it's very important development which is
why we're uh
leading with it tonight on spectator tv
and the trend was pointed out in a
spectator article earlier this week
about carl hennigan
professor at oxford university's
evidence-based medicine department he
joins me
uh now professor thanks for being on
this for us a very special
uh broadcast but it's an important issue
so i just want to try and untangle it
a little bit explain to us how we could
be having
more cases rising cases of covert
and and yet fewer fatalities and even in
some cases
fewer hospital cases right let's try and
be
this is a complex issue but i think we
can break it into sort of three areas
let's go back to march about march the
27th we went into lockdown
we had a very significant increases in
cases in a two-week period
where we got to the peak of death around
about the 8th to the 10th of april
and one of the issues about lockdown
that was very clear
is that actually disproportionately
increased the risk
in the very elderly and the care homes
all of the outbreaks in care homes
came after lockdown in an eight week
period
eighty-two percent of care homes had
infection outbreaks about six and a half
thousand
on average they have about three deaths
so there's about eighteen thousand
deaths immediately
you've got you've got and actually as a
consequence of lockdown
now there are we can discuss why that is
and they're really interesting issues
about that but the second aspect is
when people look at country comparisons
they say england's doing worse and spain
or
it's slightly better than belgium but
actually one of the keys about the care
home population is in the year before we
had a higher vulnerable
population trending in we had about 15
000 less deaths
in 2019 in that population so that means
you've got a
group of people hanging on by their
fingernails
any respiratory pathogen who gets in
that environment will be deleterious so
that's one aspect
the second aspect in pushing people into
hospital
there was a phase where there was panic
high numbers of people going on to
intensive care units
and the mortality in icu was so high
i've never seen immortality that high it
was approaching 70 80 percent whereas
for viral pneumonia
should be 20 so we've seen new
treatments come on board so that's two
aspects where we're better prepared
but then if we move forward into the
summer what's happening now is we're
seeing and this is an interesting aspect
a normalization of the risk across the
age groups
so as we come out of lockdown what
happens is as young people go about
their lives
yeah they get the infection but one of
the stunning things about this
infection risk is under 50 your risk is
virtually zero now that's not the same
for
infections like rsv influenza
which will affect young children
particularly under five so we'd be much
more worried
if we were going back to schools now
with children and influenza
the second aspect we've seen is what
we're seeing is the viral load
in individuals is less in summer
and data coming out of italy suggests
over 50 percent of the people testing
positive
are weak positives so that's where you
get the asymptomatics
people who are potentially able to have
their t-cell immunity
fight off the disease so that's two and
then i say the third issue which is
we are sort of in the trying to
understand it's our immunity and how it
affects seasonally
people are put through ideas like
vitamin d hypothesis
but also what happens as well if you're
more vulnerable towards the end of the
winter
you may have already had an infection
and one of the key bits of your
immune system is your white cells is
something called lymphocytes
and if they get worn down you are in a
bit of trouble
and that's the problem as you get older
you have this feature called
immunosenescence where your
t cells your white cells are much harder
to wake up
so across the board i think putting all
them free issues together
this is the problem i see across the
board is we keep
modeling and predicting what's going to
happen next
as opposed to up reacting to what's
actually happening now on the ground
which is what fraser put out there and
if you do that
you should open up and as we're doing
is saying look let's get schools
universities open but be vigilant while
we do that
is it too simple to say that
most of the cases now being discovered
are among younger people
and younger people are as you said less
likely to die or even
less likely to have the the symptoms and
that you can have more
cases but they're in a demographic
which doesn't suffer many fatalities
from covert so so it isn't one argument
that would explain some of it but it
doesn't explain all of the effect
because we've seen data from other
countries
that suggest even in the over 85 year
olds their case fatality rate is
plummeting
in fact in the last month we still had
in excess of 400 care home outbreaks
it's just not well publicized and i can
come back to that because that should be
our priority in winter it doesn't seem
to be
but actually their fatality has dropped
right down
and one of that is about the idea of a
susceptible population
out there for viruses is some group of
people
who will be who will die in effect even
if they get the common
cold so it they have to be shielded in
effect
so i think it's one argument that the
risk is down but it doesn't explain all
of the effect that we're seeing
the figures fraser gave her instinct
that it didn't show
much of an uptick in any uptick in
hospitalizations
which is an interesting development more
cases but not more people the health
service
not being overwhelmed by any means by it
but in france and spain which many
people think are
maybe several weeks ahead of us in these
cycles
uh they have a rise in cases and there
is now in spain and france an uptick
in hospitalizations not dramatic
but it is rising should we be worried
about that so there are interesting
aspects about
societies well if you think of france
and spain they even had
very hard lockdowns spain in effect you
couldn't yet have a pass i believe to go
out of the house you had to stay in
children you had to feel important to
leave for an hour
so it's a really interesting the first
aspect is to say what
happens when you open up when you've got
very low immunity in a population
and that's what we've seen these
sporadic outbreaks because the real
anomaly is london you've got 10 million
people
rishi's scheme has had over 100 million
people eat out in the restaurants and
the pubs
there are 47 600 pods in this country
about 40 million people have been
through them so why in somewhere like
london or in
these areas haven't you seen outbreaks
like italy and spain
so i think their immunity is very low so
as you open up remember
everybody's forgotten flattened the
curve in effect if you flatten the curve
you do not reduce the number of people
who are going to get affected
you just spread it out over a long time
so
i remember barack obama coming out and
telling us flatten the curve here we go
but now it's all been forgot
and all that was about admissions and
about death
now the interesting issue in spain i've
seen what's happening in spain
again what's happening if you go in for
a hip operation
and you have a pcr test you'll be
counted as an admission
so this comes back to the notion of
understanding
admissions within 28 days of an active
infection
and do you actually have covered
or actually are using there for
something else because covet is a
cluster of symptoms and signs
related to a pneumonia that should be
putting you
potentially into icu and i'd like to
come back to
another really important point that we
did write an article in fact the first
article we wrote about this was in the
spectator
and it was in the new york times on the
weekend as well
and we've just about to put out another
update of our review
when you do a pcr test you basically
amplify the amount of rna you
put into a dna copy and then you
exponentially double that amount of dna
and that's called the cycle threshold
and the more times you do that
the less virus you start out with
and this is important because you can
basically pick up
a single copy of rna in an individual
there is a complete difference between
you being infectious
which is about seven days from the onset
of symptoms
to about at day eight you cannot find
infectious people
apart from the few people who end up on
itu who are worsening
we have found rna shedding in
evidence for 78 days
because the rna is only 20 base pairs
long
and it takes much longer for you to
degrade the rna
so when you're picking up asymptomatic
people
you have no idea if they have active
infection
or did they have it two months ago
because you
intermittently shed this rna and it's
the same for
all viruses now you can put in a
threshold level
which says you are infectious which is
about a million
copies per mill in a sample
which is a cycle threshold of about 25
and if you do that you can pick up the
people who are infectious but the way
we're deploying the test at the moment
is in a sort of ragbag way that says
whatever amount of rna you've got on
board you are positive
and we are going to see this move
forward and we've wrote this about two
or three times in the
in the spectator and kept moving forward
the discussion
but it's now on the radar because there
are 25 studies that have now looked at
this and 10 have come in the last three
weeks
so this idea is becoming more important
well let me ask you this professor we've
seen the the figures phrase okay because
we've
heard your fascinating analysis of this
what are the policy conclusions for
government now what
at this stage in this culvert crisis
what policies should the government now
follow
giving your analysis and given phrases
figures so the first
the first issue is to understand the
function of the test and trace program
which is to let the test and trace
program
work but there's been a tendency for as
soon as you see
cases rising with this arbitrary number
of twenty
hundred thousand and then fifty per
hundred thousand you go on the red list
policy intervenes well at that point
you're saying the test and trace program
is failing so i've gone outwards and
said
you actually have to hold back as
politicians
what's the problem if a thousand people
are getting the infection if you've not
got a disease impact
yes the second issue then is you should
use the data to really follow the impact
of the disease
so if we see people with covid
increasing in hospital and icu
not going in for a hip operation actual
with disease
that's the point at which you introduce
local restriction measures
my third point is the amount of
messaging and i've spoke to lots of
people in oldham here is
about 90 percent of people are
completely ignoring the messaging
because they just don't understand it
and actually there are only three clear
bits to me is
social distancing hand washing and
being vigilant and if we kept that clear
because what you're seeing is
humane university environments that are
so restrictive in university environment
that by the time you come to the evening
there's 200 people in a house party
who are not socially distancing so they
react in different ways because the
message isn't clear
so that's two broad policies and and my
third policy and i think this is
important
is care homes i just don't understand
why nobody's got a grip of
this is an urgent area we could reduce
the death by 40
so if we say there are 42 000 deaths and
we can get rid of 16 000
suddenly you're looking at a radically
different problem
and in care homes places like hong kong
had a very clear plan
that we don't have in place and so while
we're doing all this test and tracing
we're still not testing people
in care homes every week who go in there
we still have multiple agency staff
transferring around different different
care homes
they didn't have a supply of ppe they
didn't lock down early enough
but all we have to do is when we make
the switch
is have an eight week period where you
protect care homes
therefore for instance as we've heard of
the the agency worker who flew to kent
from kent to the shetland islands while
they were in lockdown to reintroduce
introduce covid we shipped 25 000
patients potentially
directly into care homes at the same
time if we protected them for eight
weeks
you could pay people count you and just
say would you like eight weeks to stay
in a care home we're gonna give you a
proper pay
stay in there for eight weeks you don't
need many skills yeah you need the
nursing but you need to
increase that staffing level that's one
practical area where you could get rid
of 40
of the death amazing professor i hope
the government's listening to you
and i thank you for being with us a
fascinating analysis but also
some very practical policy uh
considerations that follow from it uh
professor hannigan at the university of
oxford thank you very much for being
with us on
spectator tv tonight let's turn out of
scotland it's always with us
uh this week scottish labour attempted
to depose their leader richard leonard
with four nsps are calling on the corbyn
ally to quit
before the scottish parliamentary
elections in 2021
they were really hoping to follow the
lead of the scottish tories who replaced
their own leader with douglas ross
um an ally of ruth davidson last month
all of this points to a general crisis
in the unionist camp
as the snp continues to dominate
scottish politics
and the case for independence seems to
be according to the polls
more popular among scottish voters than
it's ever been
now james forsyth of the spectator this
week said that this unionist malaysia
that's what it is can be solved he
suggested with an unusual move from
number 10
start negotiations for independence
strange could be james i know you're
serious
make the case so uh
despite the fact that the scottish
tories have got rid of jackson carla
looks like scottish labour of binding in
the get rid of richard leonard
it's still overwhelmingly likely but the
scottish national party will win a
majority of hollywood in next year's
scottish
elections as um nicholas sturgeon's
program for government speech this week
made clear
once she won a majority she would go and
demand a section firstly order allowing
a second
independence referendum at the moment
number 10's plan is
just say no to that their view is there
can be no legal referendum about
westminster's consent
and they can't lose a referendum but
they don't allow
but those people in government who think
most deeply about the union
are beginning to wonder and worry about
how sustainable that strategy is
that the big worry is this is
nicola sturgeon who's a canny politician
chooses
the right time to ask the question and
every time she asks the question and
number 10
knocks it back support for independence
goes up by a point or so
and the question of whether scotland
should be allowed to have a referendum
turns into the issue rather than whether
scotland should be independent or not
and the worry is that if support for
independence goes
over 60 you pass a kind of psychological
tipping point
and any referendum when it comes would
be seen as a complimentary exercise
rather than a debate now i mean there
are any of this increase in support for
independence
is that the economic case for
independence has never been weaker than
it is now
the price of a barrel of oil is half
what it was
on the day where the referendum was held
in 2014. in 2014 alex salmond
would say independent scotland is going
to join the eu and be part of the
customs union in the single market so
therefore there will be no disruption to
trade
with the rest of the uk that is now
clearly not the case because
uh if even if an independent scotland
succeeded in joining the eu
there would that would be a different
customs union
to the rest of the uk so there would be
trade friction at the border
and all of these weaknesses in the sap's
case for independence
are not being noticed or not affecting
voters so
you've got to change the debate from
being one about the
about feeling about the idea of
independence to the realities of it
now one very high risk way admittedly of
doing that would be this asynchronous
urgent okay
you've won a majority you could have a
referendum
but we've got to agree with terms first
you can't ask people to vote blind
we're going to sit down and we're going
to work out you know what share of a
national debt an independent scotland
would take on
what assets it would have what currency
it would use what its relationship with
the bank of england would be
uh how are we going to deal with the
military bases
and how are we going to deal with
cross-border trade
uh after independence what would be the
migration regime between
scotland and the rest of the uk what
would be the basis of citizenship
uh in scotland so force them to fresh
out all of those questions
and then when it comes the debate
about independence would not be about
the idea of it it would be about the
realities of it
now i mean there's some obvious
drawbacks to this approach the
first is that you know having these
negotiations
could make things feel inevitable and
demoralize being in a side of the
argument because you're talking about
independence
yeah secondly um
the the uk government would have to take
a relatively hard line
so as not to make independence look
attractive and you can see
that that would be playing to that usual
smp narrative about how westminster is
always trying to do down scotland
and they'd also love to frame mrs boris
v nicola which is the frame that i think
has
worked so well for doing covert and one
of the reasons why support for
independence has risen
but i think what it would do is it would
re-inject economics into this argument
about independence
uh the poll out last week suggested that
by a 10
margin scots fought but not didn't think
that independence was worth it but would
be economically difficult
they thought that scotland would be
economically better off after
independence
i mean this is a remarkable assertion
when you consider that scotland would
have
the largest deficit in the western world
when it started out as an independent
country
to join the eu it would have to get its
deficit down from over eight percent to
three percent
but none of those economic facts are
landing for the union side of the
argument right now
and i think they need to do something
bold to focus
the debate on the economic facts and the
hard
cold realities of independence rather
than
the emotional sentiments that nicholas
sturgeon has been so
adept at tapping into i want to get
fraser's taking this in a minute but
before i do
uh james wouldn't the problem with this
be that the snp
would say hold on a minute the
westminster government is going to play
a real hard ball
they're going to insist on giving us the
worst possible deal
so that when it comes to the referendum
the scots will vote not to go
independence because the deal is so
awful
and they just wouldn't play that game i
think if nicola sturgeon refused to
uh negotiate the terms of independence
i think that would create a weakness for
her it would allow me to say well you
won't negotiate because you
know that you can't make this work in
practical terms i mean that would cause
a
a problem for her and also she couldn't
really spend her time
accusing westminster of being
obstructive be the ones not allowing a
second independence referendum
if she was the brock and i think that
that
that causes a problem i also think
that even if even if the snp one of the
other
challenges people say it's look well
what if the snp
negotiated and then said to people yeah
ignore these terms
because as soon as it becomes reality
and you vote for independence
london will soften and the terms will
get better i mean that's quite a high
risk game because i think one of the
things that we are learning from brexit
is that these divorce these political
divorces
are not painless and they're not
amicable and
if you think that how hard it has been
to break up a 40 year old economic union
in some political aspects
it does make you realize that breaking
up a 300 year old political economic and
military union
would be infinitely more difficult and i
think would actually be
even more acrimonious well i think
divorce is always
acronis fraser what's your take on this
well i think right now i would have to
admit to several things which people
like me have got wrong about scottish
independence first of all i had thought
that brexit would make independence um
a less attractive option because you'd
be leaving the customs union of the uk
the single market of the uk
that has not seemed to be the case and
i thought that the the alexander trial a
lot of unionists thought
that the sheer publicity of alexander
in that courtroom day after day after
day would damage the snp
more than it has on the contrary they
look pretty much unstoppable now to get
a majority
not just any old per annual parliament
but in the pr system that was designed
to make sure
that nobody got a majority then you
our unionists thought that when the
north sea oil
collapsed the scottish financial figures
would just be
so big the deficit would be so large
that it would be pretty hard to to bat
away the institute of fiscal studies
only last week
calculated that the scottish deficit is
close to 27
of gdp now sure pandemics make things
big but nobody's got a deficit anywhere
near
as big as that but still we see the
support for independence
climb higher and the argument is made
that
scotland's dire financial situation
shows it needs independence because
within the union
things are very bad so unionists are
basically
in roughly the same position as
remainers were during their brexit
referendum talking about
like this is going to be very expensive
don't do it it will cost you a lot of
money
and then the other side say look this is
not about money
this is about liberty this is about
sovereignty this is about who we are as
a country
so when unionists who've relied for so
long on
ammunition about figures and deficits
they see this translated to the ears of
nationalistic borders thinking
scotland's too small scotland's too poor
scotland can do it
the unionist problem is how do you
manage to get the practical issues back
on the agenda how do you come up with an
attractive positive case
for the union as well as persuading
scots about the practical obstacles
to separation far outweigh now what you
need
and are articulate advocates for the
union ruth davidson's loss is pretty bad
there is look at the scottish labour
party as well they're um going through
their another
leader you don't really have anybody up
to the prowess and the eloquence
of nicholas george who's one of the most
formidable politicians i would say not
just in britain but
in europe so unionists really ought to
start panicking now
now boris johnson will say look doesn't
matter i don't have to give them a
referendum they can get a majority if
they want
i can be like the spanish government
saying to the catalans
no forget it you're not getting your
vote like
james i don't think that's sustainable i
think if the smp win a majority they've
got the moral right to ask
for that referendum and unions to better
start right now thinking how they'd win
it
gonna be a big topic it's not going away
james uh it's an intriguing idea
and i can see the attractions of it
i would suggest to you though the
government almost certainly hasn't got
the guts
to go down this road james yeah i think
this is a
i think this is a downing street that is
aware
that it that it is uncertain of scottish
politics
but it doesn't have a kind of finger tip
feel for it
and i think the kind of risk-free option
of saying no
has an appeal the thing i would say
about this is
i think number 10's big aim is not to
have a scottish independence referendum
you know capsize this parliamentary term
i think these negotiations would take a
long time
and i think if even if you embarked on
them i don't think it's realistic to
think they would be
finished between in three years between
2021 and 2024 so
i think you are most likely looking at a
referendum in the next
parliament uh in the next western
parliament
and so in a way i think you know that i
also think the union side need to
realize this
i don't think doing nothing is an option
i think if you look at the demographics
and the polling
uh sentiment is moving against the union
and i think
you need to find i mean i i mean i think
i view this
as a kind of witness referendum you
would then have a generation to build
a new positive values-based case for the
union i think
what we i think what we have failed to
appreciate is
how um devolution has separated the two
cultures and really
uh eroded the basis of the union i was
very struck the other day
um uh listening to today program they do
that newspaper review just
off six o'clock and this was just after
lockdown restrictions have been
uh imposed in in around glasgow and west
of scotland
and the presenter said um and they don't
normally look at the scottish papers
which is telling in and of itself
because of these lockdowns we'll look at
the scottish papers in much the same way
that you might say well because emmanuel
macron has decided to lock down
france again we'll look at the front
page of the figaro
and i think that common political
culture has been eroded in a really
dangerous way i think we need to
have a massive effort to get back to
having
a national conversation and a much
greater awareness at westminster
of what's involved and what's not um i
have to admit that i was writing a piece
the other day
on planning and i mean cue some frantic
googling to check
whether planning in wales is the
responsibility of the welsh assembly
or whether it's a reserve master
westminster and i mean the truth is
and this and covid has revealed this you
know government doesn't know what's
evolved or not
they they assumed to take a topical
example
with the quarantine measures changing
tonight they assume
that these quarantines would be uk-wide
they thought that because it was to do
with borders
it you know what westminster said would
determine the policy for the entirety of
the uk
what it actually turned out was because
these quarantines are a health
regulation
they're devolved so each bit of the uk
can decide what to do
and again i think all of these things
added up
are are all eroding the basis of the
union you know
i mean that we all thought i mean the
the i mean
i don't think anyone can think anymore
that devolution would kill nationalism
stone death
was telling me it was going to kill
itself
became head of nato told me that it
would kill nationalism stone dead
and it's not done so i mean the union
needs to think of different ways to
to to make and defend the union i mean
we forget that devolution the whole
devolution program
was designed as a trap for the snp to
stop them getting anywhere near here
when it was decided that no party should
get a majority what they meant was the
snp
should not get a majority it's
extraordinary that we've ended up
with the union probably more parallel
now than it's ever been in
well big test is whether boris johnson
is the prime minister to save
the union and parliament came back this
week
tory mps have been very disgruntled over
the summer they're not happy
and i doubt if they're any happier after
the prime minister's performance of
prime minister's
questions yesterday which was in my view
as someone who
has to sit and had to sit in the tv
studio and watch pnq's every week one of
the worst performances
i can remember of any prime minister and
prime minister's questions
at the dispatch box so he didn't help
himself
uh with his unhappy tory mps the morning
so much of the prime minister and the
chancellor well they went and talked to
tory m peace uh tonight and of course
katie balls had her tumblr to the door
so she could find out what was happening
katie what's happening
well i think you're right to say that
the prime minister's pmq's performance
didn't really
calm nerves i think it did the exact
opposite
and so we've had a long summer which i
think if you look at the summer recess
it didn't feel particularly relaxing for
mps um partly because they had lots of
constituents complaining when they got
stuck abroad when they had to cancel
their holidays
but then most recently the a-levels
fiasco which
really caused a lot of discontent in the
party
so coming back i think the hope had been
in government
to try and rally the troops so there are
a few
ways they plan to do this so as you say
prime minister's questions
didn't go quite to plan boris johnson
suffers from not having
done his homework yeah suffers from not
having done his homework he also suffers
from not having that many mps behind him
so because the chamber's still socially
distanced those who would cheer for him
or rally him on
aren't really there and i think that
does impact him but then
you go from prime minister's questions
to a joint address to
the new intake the 2019 mps that
includes the red wall mps
and where both the chancellor and the
prime minister tried to
rev them up and but ultimately it's
quite a sobering appearance
from what i'm told uh from mps who who
were there
and the chancellor's message was you're
hearing about
tax risers i'm not going to say they're
not going to happen but i promise you it
won't be a complete
endless horror show and it just might be
a bit tricky and then the prime minister
backed rishi cena cup by saying you know
it has been tough but you know what it's
going to get tougher so
it wasn't the most optimistic but i
think what number 10 we're trying to do
is try and uh warn these mps that you
know things aren't going to be difficult
but therefore everyone needs to stick
together
but i think probably where we got the
biggest flavor or sense of where the
party are
was uh boris johnson's appearance later
that day
and at the 1922 committee
and that appearance i think one mp uh in
the room said
to me you couldn't exactly describe it
but a barnstorming speech
and it wasn't nearly as bad as pmq's but
that had already happened
and the prime minister made plenty of
jokes there wasn't too much social
distancing going on in the room
he said they were all cheeked by jowl
and actually looking at them not
socially distancing
it made him think of what he wanted to
get to at christmas which is some sense
of normality
and so he wanted people to be able to be
in the room
like the tory mps were but but allowed
to do that
and and talked a bit about you know
the uh what's coming up but i think
when you looked at the questions of mps
there are a few quite hostile questions
um so one mp suggested that boris
johnson was a prisoner in number 10
um to which boris johnson kind of shook
her off and suggested he wanted to hug
everyone
and then you had another question uh
which an mp
complained that when it came to number
10 how they handled the parliamentary
party
and they said too often mps feel as
though their patients
in number 10's hospital the idea being
number 10 will deal with them but they
want them out you know they want them
out as quickly as possible
and to which boris johnson replied no
you're all doctors
you know you're very important to this
um but i don't think it was
particularly uh soothing to those in the
room and i think as you can see
what's going on in public the mp's going
out and criticizing
there's still a lot of discontent and
just a light level of comedy from the
meeting was because it was a 1922
committee
you have boris johnson and either side
of him you had graham brady
the chair of the 1922 committee and
charles walker
vice chair now charles walker's been
very vocal
in the media about his issues and graham
brady is known to be rather unhappy
uh particularly following his area um so
boris johnson began by
suggesting that he did realize there was
some discontent but he
he appreciated that uh the people
weren't going public with that
which everyone should be a little bit
thinly veiled at the people next to him
all right katie thanks you're watching
spectator tv
this is the week in 60 minutes uh
sponsored by our friends at the netwest
group
james let me come straight to the heart
of this are there a growing number of
conservative mps
beginning to wonder not allowed but
perhaps
to wonder in their mumbles that boris
johnson just
isn't up to this job of being prime
minister
i i think the pmq's performance was
i mean i started one former cabinet
minister last night and i mean their
sense was it was disrespectful to the
commons to
turn up not having done your homework i
mean
and there are a lot of tory mps who
would quite like to
make boris johnson take parliament more
seriously uh
i would give you uh i wouldn't give you
any odds better than even
on before christmas the government
either losing a vote in the commons
or having to pull one because it is
going to lose one the
mood is is crosstalk
yeah and i think i think one of the
things we're learning is that this
we all assumed that this majority of 80
on election night
it was big it was sizable and we assumed
that that meant
you know political stability
and the government was basically going
to be able to do what it wants wanted i
mean that's what the government
thought i mean the government imagined
that it would be able to take on
difficult big issues like planning
reform
because that majority was big enough
ultimately to absorb
you know a normal sized rebellion i
think what we're finding is that this
majority of 80
is is much more like the majority that
john major won in 1992
than the majority that margaret patcher
won in 1987.
mps are more rebellious these days
party loyalty is less and but i think an
underestimated factor is
but there's toxins from both the 2019
and 2016 leadership contests
are still in the tory bloodstream uh
it used to be the case in the tory party
that he who wielded the knife
never wears the crown boris johnson in
many ways wielded the knife of theresa
may and now wears the crown and i think
some of those who don't come from his
brexit wing of the party
will struggle to forgive him for that
and in the parliamentary party
fraser they people cut the prime
minister some slack
when the call of the crisis started it
was uncharted territory
mistakes were bound to be made we didn't
really know much about it
they cut out some cycle he got covered
himself very bad
a dose of covert he was 50 50 whether he
would have survived or not
so people understand all that but we're
six months into this now
and there's still it seems to me a lack
of sense of direction
of competence uh of the government just
knowing what it's doing
uh from the top down that has to be no
we're a long way from the next election
but that has
to be that has to erode the government's
position
if they don't get a grip of this uh
before christmas
i would suggest it has in an important
way that right now
only a few months after winning the
majority of 80 the government already
has a problem handling parliament so
for example there was they made a plan
to do early release for prisoners that
they had to abandon because they
couldn't get it through parliament
and james revealed recently there's a
planning bill coming up
that they're planning a rebellion for
there they won't be able to get their
planning bill
through unless they make some serious
concessions so already a government that
should really be laying down the law to
parliament is having to chop and change
his policies
because of how much and just worry there
is not so much about the prime minister
himself but about his modus operandi
about how he conducts his government so
rather than
having cabinet members that he trusts
and empowers he's got a lot of power in
number 10
and number 10 seems to be visibly
buckling under the strain
of this one of the things that we've
heard recently is well dominic cummings
has been away in holidays about
explaining the chaos
now that's not very encouraging i mean
this isn't a corner shop in october
where if one guy's away the whole outfit
comes down this is supposed to be the
british government so concerns are not
so much about boris though there are
concerns about him but the whole way
this government is being run katy i'm
going to take some questions from our
audience in a minute in our final
10 to 12 minutes but what rumblings do
you detect among
touri back benches it's early days
they're pretty much a loyal bunch um but
what
rumblings what concerns are they having
about the prime minister at the moment
well i think there are several concerns
and there's several things they can do
i don't think we're at the point where
everyone's anyone's thinking you know is
borrowed to be prime minister in a year
um but i think
there's concerns over uh ultimately the
chancellor's plans for the budget over
spending
i think there are concerns really about
how numbers had operates and i think
that question about whether boris
johnson was a prisoner
in number 10 hit on that and i think
that we might start to see
an anti-dominant cummings movement and
things keep keep hard we know there's
a lot of energy very unhappy of him
since barnard castle
but i think that if you look at how that
might manifest itself um
one thing is for example you have
projects very closely linked to
that advisor so arpa you know investment
in these things
and i think that depending how things go
i think when there is a
lack of morale people could try and move
to try and stop those pet projects i
think that's one thing
um and i think i'm planning i mean it's
in a way a very important reason for the
government but speaking to mps tonight
i'm even hearing that they're hearing
that might be pushed back a bit
um until after the local elections next
year because it's too tricky so
i think we're gonna start to see that
anger in terms of
votes being either pulled so they don't
lose them or you know tricky when you
get there
all these stories about huge tax rises
that are in
the pipeline other than that this is
just
their raise and attempt to do them down
i don't really understand why they're
going this room
because there is no possible tax rise
that uh could
do much about the deficit at all the
deficit's so huge
and if you did have attacked rise and it
could do something about it
it would probably destroy the economy
yeah you could make the standard rate of
income tax
forty percent you could make v80 30
you just kill the economy in doing that
so why
why are they talking about about this in
this way
i think it's confusing a lot of tory mps
and i think the biggest problem rishi
sunek has when it comes to
all these things being muted is there is
just not a general sense in the party
that this is necessary
particularly right now but i think it
goes into
if you look in the long term i think
there's a real concern in the treasury
not about
trying to pay off this deficit as you
say huge sums
but the fact that if you continue on the
current path we are particularly because
the economy
could indeed be shrinking if we go on
this rate and we won't be able to
maintain the level of spending
that's it that they expect which is why
i think we are looking
at and hearing at these various measures
but
they're all going to be very difficult
and again i think
there are questions as to even if we are
definitely going to have you know have a
budget even because everything's so
unpredictable
but i think that the chance that it's
going to have to convey this but i think
it goes down to the fact that
there is a worried that the economy we
are left with at the end of this is
going to be smaller and therefore that's
going to have big impacts on spending
and it's not something that i think is
registered or the view in the treasury
is it's not registered with many mps
well we know there are problems the
fiscal position is difficult though
interest rates are though
but the tories have told us for ten
years that they cut corporation tax we
get more revenue
now they're telling us if we raise
corporation types we'll get more revenue
well the both things can be true and
they need to make up their minds
what is true let me see if look rick
who's got his
digital hand up look are you there would
you like to ask a question
yes i'm here can you hear me yes look on
you go please
hello so my question is given one of the
key lessons learned from brexit and
trump
is that feelings matter more than facts
isn't it exactly the wrong approach to
focus on scottish finances
in the next independence debate
fraser um i think it has to be both
certainly the unionists lack an
emotional argument right now
and for me as a unionist it's entirely
emotional i think the british government
is
something which made my whole my life
story possible my dad
left school at 15 he joined the the
british military
you know there are so many ways in which
i think about what why would you want to
make
foreigners out of our family and friends
in other parts of the uk
but um they're not used to talking this
way i think
for decades you must have said look
here's a spreadsheet here's the answer
big deficit
off the agenda so yes i think the
emotional the positive case needs to be
made
but i do think we need to find a way of
getting the practical issue salient
again because ultimately
that is the trump card and the scots
like to vote with their head as well as
their heart and so you're right it is a
double bag
denise butler i see your digital hand is
waving at me would you like to ask a
question
[Music]
nope we seem to have lost denise let me
try caroline stevens
caroline stevens can we have you for a
question
no they're all very shy these people let
me just try one more
andrew richardson yeah i'm here i'm here
i'm here yes okay
let's have your question oh somebody
knew somebody knows the technology here
um what i would like to ask is
about the falsification of death
certificates
um i've interviewed a few people who
have had family members uh die
in hospital um or even not even in
hospital but they've had
uh they've been resuscitated and then
then passed away and they've actually
been put on their death certificate
as dying of covert whereas actual fact
they died from a heart attack
uh this must surely distort the figures
somewhat
good question caroline james we saw that
the government itself had to change the
way it was calculating
that if you had been diagnosed covered
then you were a covert death no matter
if you died a month two months
afterwards and when it changed that
uh suddenly the number of corporate
deaths fell it's been
i mean i know it's been difficult to do
these are new ways it's uncharted
territory but it's been a bit of a mess
is it not
yeah i think it was carl who actually
pointed out in
a piece of the spectator that it was it
was an impossibility to recover from
kobit in england you could
you know have kobe recover leave the
hospital be
heading home to see your family to
celebrate and be hit by the 38 bus
and you would count as a cobra death i
mean i i i think this is a
i think this is an issue and i think
there is also i mean
and as i understand it it was it was
carl's work that actually alerted
the government to the fact that public
health england was was miscounting
uh the number of deaths and i think one
of the things that
is striking is i mean people right now
one of the challenges to government
people right now are
more fearful i think than they should be
if they knew the precise numbers
of what what is going on right now i i
mean
it's very interesting one of these
challenges of of getting people to come
back to their offices
back to use public transport i think
people have a feeling that if they
get on a tube train they are
likely to be uh in a train which has
someone with code on it and
carl would know more than me but my
reading of statistics is you'd be highly
unlucky
to have anyone on your tube train who
had covered given the prevalence in the
population right now
let me try a few more questions susie
clark can you hear me would you like to
ask a question
susie clark yes hi
hi hi a great start to spectator
tv by the way i'm really enjoying it um
i
as a company director of an events
company in the west end of london
i'd just like to know what the thinking
is behind putting corporation tax up
when so many companies in the
hospitality sector are on their knees
already
it's a very good question frieza i don't
quite understand this
uh either mr karma wanted to put
corporation tax up
because he said it would generate more
revenue and he would use that money
to pay for his spending plans the tori
said oh if you put it up that much
uh you won't get more money companies
will leave or they'll find ways of
avoiding paying it
and so on and now we have we're being
briefed
the the tories are thinking of putting
corporation tax up
what's going on particularly at a time
when companies have got cash flow
problems
and are struggling to hold on to the
employees that they have the points
raised by susie
what's happening well actually my
understanding is that corporation tax
isn't one of the main things being
considered in the treasury
right now and there was some we're
talking about some of the times that was
the case but
they're thinking far more capital gains
tax is far more likely to go up
um lowering the money
even if you put it up to the level of
income tax it doesn't raise
that much money oh you bet i mean and
you're also quite right andrew
in the cameras in osborne eras we were
told that actually lowering capital
gains tax means more
revenue and by the way it was actually
true i mean you produce corporation tax
reduce tax on
jobs you get more workers but
interestingly i mean
they've ruled out in the manifesto any
taxes
on income tax on vat so where does that
leave you but only are there a few more
places
where you can go to raise taxes um and
rishi sunday is trying to make this
point he's saying to his party look
you guys want all this extra spending
well there's got to be a bill for it
and if we're ruling out all of these
taxes it only leaves us with a few other
ones
and but might they break the manifesto
pledge and just
increase income taxes anyway i suspect
they probably will because they're never
going to even
like we all know i mean susie's quite
right corporation tax isn't going to
raise much money
neither is capital gains if you want to
tax to fill a hole
you're going to have to break the
manifesto pledge so if anyone watching
this thinks their income tax is safe
for the next five years i would um
suggest you think again
very well let me take your final
questions a written one from
chris uh i think i pronounce it michael
zuk
uh and james i'll put this one to you he
it's a simple question
what happens if the snp just holds its
own referendum regardless
it wouldn't have any legal standing and
i think the
nicola sturgeon has uh privately always
resisted that option because
she thinks it would scare off you know
sensible scots you know who who just
think it was a bit too radical a bit
a bit too out there and she wants to
make
independence a very respectable almost
establishment
choice or establishment choice for the
new scotland
to use the xmb terminology i do
think though that if if the uk
government keeps on saying no
i am regardless of how many times the
smp wins majorities
i think i mean this will end up in the
courts i think it will be remember the
corrugation case started in the scottish
courts
i think there will be an attempt to use
the courts to try and force the
government's hand i think
saying no won't be the end of the matter
all right we'll leave it there thanks to
all of you who have joined our debut of
the week in 60 minutes
as you can see a little bit rough on the
edges here and there but we'll get the
hang of it as the
weeks go ahead we'd like to know what
you thought what you think
we should be doing how we can improve i
mean certainly
get rid of the three we had on tonight
from start that would be a big
improvement we'll keep the professor
naturally the only
real professional amongst them uh let us
know what you thought you can do so by
emailing spectator tv
at dot spectator.co.uk that's spectator
tv at spectator dot
co dot uk but that's it for this
historic event in british broadcasting
of spectator tv we'd like to thank nat
west
the northwest group our sponsors for
being with us and
for being supportive of this event we
did tonight
we'll see you same time same place next
week stay safe until then bye bye